Just, um, we're gonna install it
and just want to remind you, uh,
refresh your memory about what we
were talking about before the break.
So we were talking about, uh, first, um,
the concept of strangers and kindness
of strangers, right? Um, that, um,
um, that Lena would be a recipient of. Um,
and then we would harking
about, um, the, um,
about neighbors and what could come to us,
um,
from neighbors and not always good things.
Um,
and high tower is the
recipient of the novel.
Always good things coming from
our neighbors, but high towers,
we also know,
um,
it's very emphatic that in spite of
what happens to him in spite of the
beatings, um, and so on, um,
that he is actually
surrounded by two people.
So it really takes a
tremendous act of willpower,
um,
to be able to say that. Um, and so
this is the quote from hightower.
They are good people.
All that any man can hope for is to
be permitted to live quietly among his
fellows.
Um,
so it is a proposition statement that
really is sort of thrown in our face and
in the phase of all the things that have
happened to him. Um, so today we'll,
I like to do is to use race as the
test case for house proposition.
We all know that Joe Christmas,
um,
is someone who's racial
identity is ambiguous.
I would say from beginning to end.
We don't really know for sure. Um,
what his parentage, um, I mean,
you know, we have some very,
we have good guesses but we don't know
for sure and we certainly don't know the
genetic make up of someone
like Joe Christmas. So in the,
in that context,
um,
I think it's especially relevant to
talk about some of the contemporary
discussion of race. Um, and um,
and this is not even so new. I
mean it was, came out in 2003,
um,
it was the special issues and to make
American whether it raised exist and it
makes a strong argument,
um,
that racism is leading in the
sense that we look at the physical
characteristics,
the facial features of people,
and we assume that res has a very
solid existence that is real.
Um, but actually the facial
characteristics with the
physical attributes do not
always correspond to our genetic makeup.
So you know,
how people look.
Hatchway um,
it's not a very good way to tell us
who they are are biologically. Um,
and so the scientific argument,
special issue or that essay is about the
importance of thinking outside of the
box of noticeable,
of servable visible characteristics,
um,
to thinking about medical,
you know,
what would come into play in a medical
situation if this is scientific American
after all. Um, so this is,
this was back in 2003 and
even earlier than that,
I'm on the front cover of Time magazine
is to face new phase of America.
Um, and it's really about America
becoming mixed race nation. Um,
this is, um, and in find out his case, you
know, I look at, you know, everyone, yeah,
we're not quite often they can't really
tell, you know, what background, uh,
ethnic background people from,
um, and that is the case.
This is computer generated image.
Um, and we don't really know.
She's made up of the trays are many
razors and so it's hard to tell,
but just a very typical American face.
Um,
and around the same time
a book came out by um,
f James Davis called who
is black ash like this. Um,
it was quite an important but when it
came out in 1992 to such an extent that
and its 10th anniversary, PBS
actually did the special program, um,
title who is black and feature that
book. Um, and his argument is very,
very hurt and um, to Faulkner's novel, um,
we don't actually know, um,
who is black and this novel.
So it is a question that is not answer.
Um,
and it'll has not men today and
struggle even at the end of the novel.
And this is, um, um, image that, um,
as the Tao use for her
section and great section.
I'm very happy to be there. Um, but this
is, um, so I just borrow it from her.
Um, and this is, uh, Ebony
magazine, a quiz, um,
1952 again,
but even back in 1952,
um,
people were realizing that
if you look at people,
you don't really know what race
they are. Um, and so, you know,
I think the most who are as they get
a few wrong answers for that quiz. Um,
so I think that all of this is just
to set the stage for the ferry,
um, complicated, um,
and maybe not men to be resolve
landscape that Faulkner is set up for us.
Um, and in light in August. Um,
and so what I like to talk about today
is the one Nager and of course, you know,
that's the word that would have to be
used because just as in the 50 is the word
Negro, uh, was the standard term. Um,
in the twenties and thirties,
a nigger,
whether have been the standard term.
So it was not a racial slur.
They use the word nigger. And, um,
even though it wasn't
necessarily a racial slur,
it nonetheless was a charge appetite.
Um,
it always is,
has carry excessive semantic burden,
um,
and because it carries
excessive semantic good and, um,
it also opens itself up to multiple users.
So today we'll lock,
look at the way that word is being
used by different people in different
contexts and for different purposes.
So that will go down and let's change out.
We'll be talking about all of this, um,
and also spoken by other people.
Um,
and also when the words
spoken by the person himself.
So,
um,
just noticed this microphone has
a way of diminishing yourself.
Um, so, um, the,
these are the people that we'll be
looking at who use the word nigger. Uh,
first is,
uh,
Joe Brown and the the dietician a couple
of times and then hide and then Bobby
the waitress, and then join the
burden. And then Joe Christmas himself,
he uses the, what negative for
himself. Um, but first let's talk,
look at the way Joel Brown uses that word.
Um,
at this point to arise being questioned
by the shower of rain. So, you know,
we know that,
um,
the join his body has been discovered
and know that the house has burned down.
Um, and the sheriff is
questioning, um, uh,
Joe Brown and um, and there's $1,000, um,
that is up for, you know, anyone
who can help solve the case.
So Joe Brown is who have high hopes
that he will be the one to get $2,000.
But as the sheriff questions
in more and more comes out,
it seems as little less analyzed
likely that the thousand dollars,
we'll begin his own pocket.
So He's getting desperate and that is
when that word comes up because they said
it was like he had been saving.
He told them next
[inaudible] time is like,
he didn't know that ever come
to a pinch is with this is um,
Brian talent,
my towel,
like in head note that if it come
to a pinch, this would save him,
even if it was almost worse for a white
man to knit what he would have to admit
than to be accused of the murder
itself as right. He said, he says,
go on,
accuse me accused.
The white man is trying to help you with
what he knows accused of white men and
let the nigger go free accused to white,
let them nigger run.
So this is the classic race card,
you know,
that we recognize so well and
unfortunately it still has some currency.
Um,
and um,
so he's playing the race card
because he's really desperate.
What is really interesting is
how subtle there's portrayed.
Even have someone like Joe Brown who
is sold little saving grace to him.
You know, this is a really someone
who's supremely unlikable. Um,
but even for someone who
is supremely unlikable,
Foglia nonetheless portrays him as
someone who's not incapable of feeling the
shame.
Right?
So it is shameful even for someone like
Joe Brown to use the race car that you
know, that this is when he is not,
when there's nothing else he can do,
he would do that.
So he's not such a racist
or such or whatever the,
he is blind to what he's doing.
And so I would say that even though
this is Joe Brown doing one of the
despicable things that
he's capable of doing, um,
in the very act of doing that,
um,
he recognizes completely that
he is being despicable. Um,
so this is one kind of self
contained usage, shameful,
shameful, even to the
person who was doing it. Um,
and the next,
uh,
couple of usages or revolving
around the Dietitian.
Um, and we know that, that,
um, Joe Christmas is, um,
in the,
in behind the curtains and watching
this whole scene unfolding between,
um,
the dietician and her bowl and eating
toothpaste and having no idea what's going
on outside, but the Dietitian thinking
that he knows everything. So he,
she drags him out. Um, and, um,
this is what Joe sees when she drags
him out with phase you no longer smooth
pink and white surrounded now
by wild and disheveled hair,
who's moved bands? Once Megan
things candy, you low rat,
then fear is,
was his new logo rat despite,
I mean you little nigger
past it. Um, so at,
she's never called it that before.
So is it at this moment of x,
Rheem from ability on the part
of the dietician that that would,
would come rushing up.
So this,
it has some relation to the Joe Brown
usage in the sense that this is the word
that comes out, um, when, when,
when your back is against the
wall basically, you know, um, you,
this is the thing that, that,
that you fling at people. Um,
but the Dietitian actually is more
resourceful than um, Joe Brown.
She last today is, I'm able to use
that word in some other contexts.
So this is the next and storm and after
the word nigger coming out of the mouth
of the Dietitian and she has
something else to offer Joe Christmas
and it's out fresh and upon it,
they assume the dollar of voice
when on Bush and tens fast,
a whole dollar city. How was you could
buy something to eat every day for a week.
And that's what of maybe
I'll give you another one.
You seem to see rent tubes of toothpaste,
like word work and listen.
Terrifying.
His whole being coiled and were
rich and passion. That revision.
I don't want no more. He said,
I don't never want to know more.
He said he didn't need to look up
to know what her face looked like.
Now Tau,
she's like,
tell him your little negative
asked of you nigger bastard.
So this is the evolution of the Dietitian,
um,
that she's not so vulnerable now that
she's actually on the verge of going on
the offensive, but not quite because
she'll just wants to make peace.
Really. She has ones to have it cut a
deal with Joe Tresona's is basically,
um,
and so what she doesn't understand is
that he doesn't understand the concept of
bribery. Um, Joe Prisma is really
interesting. Um, in that way.
He doesn't always understand kindness,
um,
and even doesn't understand the next
thing down. I think it was just bribery.
Um,
and so for him,
if the silver dollar just means endless
tubes of toothpaste and can be more,
uh, that can be more repugnant to him. Um,
but he knows enough to know that rejecting
that silver dollar will actually be
an automatic guarantee of the appearance
of that worth from the Dietitian.
So the pattern is beginning to develop
first complete vulnerability on a pole or
the Dietitian, um, then now
of complete vulnerability,
but of something her skin is being
stolen and willingly by Joe Christmas,
and that word comes up again. So
it's just a killer of handy, uh,
while involuntary, but, um,
quite reflective and taught handy almost
in his true Manto usage of that term.
Um,
and we'll move on now to come
see the instrumental light usage.
Right? So with the dietician, they
begins with a nonindustrial mental eyes,
uh, involuntary usage. By the
third time she, she uses that word.
It is completely instrumental
eyes and completely calculated.
And as when the dietician goes to the
matron of the orphanage and uses that word
and they go one more time,
how does she know about this?
The dietician did not look away.
I didn't, I have no idea at all.
Of course I knew it didn't mean anything.
When the other children called him a
nigger nigger you consider the other
children they have been calling
him and they go over for years.
Sometimes I think the children have a
way of knowing things like wrong people,
your and my age don't see it
down to that little detail.
People of your age, of your and my age,
they actually are not the same age.
So, um, when you have some of the
using that kind of construction,
you just know that they are
who completely, you know,
the highly manipulative and know
exactly what they're doing. Um,
so that little giveaway
to tell at the end,
it's basically just the kind of a smore
is just the icing on the cake of this
racialization, this very deliberate, um,
racialization of Geo prisoners in order
to get them sent away from the off an
edge. Um, so the dietician
I would say is probably,
um, you know, it's right up there
in my mind along with Joel Graph,
uh, in terms of unlikeability, uh,
but she is better I think,
um,
at what she is doing and it's just
so she was like six succeeds in, um,
in pinning that adverts hat,
uh, on Joel Christmas. Um,
and so this is really the first thing
that we should say about their habitat is
that it is something
that someone else can,
it doesn't really rule from inside your,
um,
it is knowledge nanotech attribute
about you as an attribution is not an
internal genetic congenital attribute.
It is an attribution Dennis
foisted upon you. Um,
and that is what the dietician
is doing right there.
So, um, that's,
that is the usage of the word
nigger on one side of the spectrum,
joke Brown.
And that vision,
and now we'll move on to the other and
the spectrum when his sheer agony to use
that look for. By the time the
dietician uses the word last time,
she was actually very
good at what she's doing.
It doesn't really touch her anymore.
It's just completely distance yourself
and therefore able to manipulate at work.
But um,
here is on the other side of the spectrum
and someone who simply cannot have
that distance from that word.
And so it was an agonizing usage.
And this comes out in the context
of the conversation between,
um, uh, between hightower
and Byron and Byron,
this telling him about
this new development,
about it burning down the house,
join his body and so on. Uh,
but also about Christmas,
Christmas about yesterday and Christmas,
Christmas is on nigger about
him and Brian yesterday
[inaudible] I'd houses,
it's always announce the Leighton Trilio
[inaudible] bloom falling into silence
without a sound,
without any weight.
He does not move for a moment longer.
He does not move then the sales to come
over his whole body as if it's paws.
When mobile life phase features that
shrinking and denial and baron sees that
the still flattered big phase
is done lists like with sweat,
but his voice is light and calm.
What about prisoners? And Brian,
yesterday he said,
so it is that other disparity
between the bodily gesture,
the facial expression,
that bodily expression, um,
high tower and the still control,
lightness of tone is bad,
is what gives the hideout away.
Um,
bad not only is
the possibility of Joel
Christmas being black now,
not only is there the most
terrifying of possibilities,
but their sole terrify take really
afford to her knowledge is gravity,
right? So it's not as that, it's just
terrible, but he can't even men too.
It is that double double combination
that suggests just have rave.
The situation is,
um,
because the high Mao and knows
exactly what's going to happen.
And once the question
of race comes into play,
there's probably just one
outcome. Um, you know,
he knows it from his own personal history,
from what has happened to him,
to his coat, um, and there was
really nothing compared with this.
So it's just a terrible scenario.
Um,
the endpoint of what she can already
see and that's why he's behaving in this
particular way. Um, but this is also
a point, the kind of the division,
the lightness or tone it and accomplish
involuntary shrinking as well. And,
and just just, um,
just, just um, you know,
just just kind of devastation
that's kind of coming over, um,
hide how it points to the doubleness
of try talent. Another thing is world.
I'm talking about this
as a slight digression,
but thought that was really fairly
emphatic about the two phases of Itel.
Um, I think that sometimes we tend
to see him too much as a victim, um,
and certainly was hammered to him,
um,
and vices to think of him as just
a victim of his neighbors violence,
but fathers and felt it
from beginning to end.
The his two faced his face
is this one go on and flabby.
It is as though there were two phases,
one imposed upon the other.
Looking out from believe the Peo boss
scouts rather by fringe agree here from
behind the twin motionless glares or this
battery goes down to the twin glares.
Misbeck nickel until the earliest moment.
We know that means coming off the children
and reporters were taking a picture
of him and they took a picture of him
from the sign. It looks like Satan, um,
down to this moment.
Um,
when this lightness of tone is belied by
the involuntary shrinking of his body,
um, hide how it seems to be the meeting
place for two contradictory impulses.
Um, and so we can also say that, you know,
metaphorically he is also the meeting
place for the goodness of strangers and
the brutality of your neighbors.
He really is a kind of unresolved meeting
place for those two cross Cameron's
um, and so, but right
now, right there, um,
he's trying his best to trivialize that
event right in and say that it really is
nothing at RBS is of no
consequence. Um, we'll,
we'll get one coming now to Bali,
the waitress,
we look at one instance,
another instance of someone trying to
trivialize that that fact the possibility
that joke would be black.
So this is the two of them lying,
lying in bed. Um, and he
makes this confession.
I got some negative [inaudible] then
she'd be publicly still with the different
stillness.
The heat in our seem to notice it.
He laid peacefully to his hands,
low up and down and flat.
You're what you said? I think I got
some negative blood on his hands.
His eyes would close his hands
go and see thing. I don't know.
I believe I have, she did not move.
She said the ones you're lying.
Alright. He said not moving
his hand, not seizing.
I don't believe that who voice
said in the darkness. Um,
so you know,
I think that the Foglight is going out
of his way to make this a very peaceful
scenario.
So this is the equivalent of their
likeness of tone that hide how has using,
when he's facing the possibility,
the joke prisoners is black and here Joe,
Mrs Making that concession itself
but really doesn't know. Um,
but all in emphasis here is
on how peaceful the stain is.
Just stroking her. He doesn't stop
when he makes that confession.
So it's as if nothing is happening.
It wants to create the illusion
that nothing is happening,
but actually everything is happening,
right?
So the waitress bobbies reaction goes
along with the pretense that this was
really nothing she can completely,
she's not going to believe in it.
There's nothing to it.
Um, but we also know that,
that that takes a lot of
willpower, that, that assertion.
I don't believe it. Others not
into it. You're just imagining it,
all those statements as they take a lot
of willpower to say and how official
that the surgeon is becomes clear
when something else happens.
Um, and then body uses the
word nigger at one more time.
This time in a completely different
tone of voice is, um, there's,
there's much later when
Joe has killed within his,
killed his first foster father
in the kitchen accidentally. Um,
and now he's going to see body one more
time and now they know that they have to
leave, that they're in big trouble. Um,
so this is a moment of duress.
The equivalent of the dietitians duress,
the equivalent of Joe Brown's duress.
And this is what body says under duress.
It was very much like it
had been in the schoolhouse.
Someone holding her as she
struggled and Sri for hair,
wild who the joking and passing the phase,
even her mouth and contrast their hair
as still as a bad mouth in a death face
pastor's son of a bitch getting made
into a jam that always truly you like a
white man,
a white man.
Perhaps John did not hear
or not a screaming waitress.
He told me himself he was
nigger the son of a bitch.
Me F worth for nothing.
The negatives and the verbage that
would get me in a jam with club Harper
police. Um, so this is um,
this is not by design,
it is involuntary usage,
but it is to Helen that that's the word
that all of us or at least every single
one,
every single character in light in August,
which for that is the word that would
come in voluntarily into our mouths when
we are under duress.
Um,
it also says that no matter what good
intentions we have or how much willpower
we hope to bring to bear
on a racialized situation,
that that will power is always going
to be an equal to the terrible wait
semantic weight that comes with that
words that every individual effort to
lighten or trivialize that appetite
area town to make light of it.
It's going to fail.
There's as Polly and now than possible
meaning for worldwide in artists that
this is an town of various people to
make light of the phenomenon of race and
are succeeding. Um, so, um, this, um,
the Bobby is, is in
that sense not even, uh,
especially interesting character
on their own other than, um,
as a kind of a dramatize and
concentrated version of the suit,
the involuntary reactions and involuntary
usage of that word when we are
ourselves under the rest, um, below
these are really quite marginal,
thicker hide. How isn't um, isn't
all that marginal. But, um, he,
uh,
his reaction is in many ways is an
entry point into his psychology,
but there's one person for whom the
word nigger is front and center.
And, and in many ways, um,
she is more extreme to be
a generalized case. So, um,
faculty uses join of burden,
um,
as a fairly atypical case of thinking for
emotional response to the word nigger.
Um, that is in many ways on
the far end of the spectrum.
The nonetheless refers on the medium
on me and have that spectrum. Um,
but she has this very extreme notion
of what the word nigger mean is,
which is that it is an eternal curse.
Um,
and the context of which is the death
of her grandfather and her half brother
Calvin.
Okay.
So her grandfather and her half brother
Calvin were killed by a white person.
They were killed by,
to torrid.
So there's no forget that they will not
kill by black girls and they were killed
by way person.
But this is the account that Joanne or
with Gif of the reason why the two of
them are killed.
Oh,
this is what her father says to her.
Your grandfather and brother aligned.
They're murdered now by one white man,
but by the curse,
which got put on the whole race before
your grandfather or your brother or me or
you ever thought of race,
Dune and cause to be forever and ever a
part of the weight reasons do and curse
for us since remember that his doom and
his clothes forever and never mind your
mother's yours.
Even though you are a child,
the curves of every white child that was
born and that ever will be born now can
escape it.
This is about as thorough
going occurs as could be.
It's basically comprehensive cover all
the bases covers every single member of
the white race and it goes on for an
eternity that occurs when there were go
away.
So why is it that when two white people
are killed by another white person,
that that is the case of
the coast of the black race.
That is a really interesting bit of logic,
but um,
doing his father and is firmly
convinced that that is the case,
that if they had not been
blacks in this world,
um, [inaudible] is true if
they had not been blessing.
And as well, the rand father and Calvin
would not have been killed pastor Torres.
So even though it seems like a strange
kind of logic once you spell it out in
that way, actually it is a strange
when as truthful statement I think.
Um,
and this was how Joanna
Russ interpretation of
that statement elaboration,
um,
on that image of eternal,
of raised as an internal occurs
on the bladder obviously,
but also on the waste as well.
And given her fathers with her
father says [inaudible] uh,
this is what she herself things.
But after that I seen to see
them relax for the first time,
not as people but as a thing,
a shallow in which I live,
we lived or when people are other people.
I've thought of all the children coming
forever and never and into the world
wait with the blast,
shallow already falling upon
them before they air to breath.
And I seem to see the black shadow in
the shape of a cross and they seemed like
the white babies were struggling even
before the two Braf to escape from the
shower who was not only upon them but
being leave them to flung up like the arms
were flung up as if they
were nailed to the cross.
I saw all of the little babies
than would ever be in the world.
The ones not yet even born a long line
of them with upon spread on the black
cross. So this is a modern
interpretation of Christopher sick of,
of, of the reason and
high res being crucified.
And it turns out that according
to join her and her father,
that the dynamics of race and the legacy
of slavery is such that wise will be
crucified apart the black cross for,
for as long as they live for as long
as they are human beings on earth.
Susan extravagant claim. Um, but,
um,
and it's predicated on the notion,
um, then in some sense,
this is summary of our,
that we're seeing so far,
which is that the ratio appetite is in
fact and habitat that offers which for
him voluntarily when we are under arrest,
right?
So it's almost a kind of psychological
necessity for us to call someone the
whack, um, that of us as human beings.
And because our hours are under
duress so much of the time,
there's just no way to have weighing
in uninjured as some of the time, uh,
because they're such good chances for
all of us to be under different. Yes.
They also good chances for all of
us to call someone back. Right?
We're just need to,
to make that kind of
attribution, um, to someone.
Um,
and it's because of that basic human
psychological need that the relations
between the races so called races,
even though the membership of each one,
there's always going to be in flood,
but the relation between
the simple certain races,
that relation is always
going to be fraught,
always going to be terrible relation.
Um,
and that's why according to Joe Hannah,
the is not just as black
shadow falling on white babies,
but she actually go so far as to say that
that shadow is underneath them as well.
It is an incredibly detailed all
encompassing black challenge basically
envelops. Everyone is on top
of you, is underneath view,
your arms has flung out and
the follows the con, you know,
the shape of your arms
basically completely envelops
every image of you. Um,
there's no escape from that black coast.
So this is a really incredible claim.
Um,
and I think that it's helpful in order
to contextualize their claim to think
about the burden
genealogy. So this is, um,
another, you know, this unsure father
with the objective is kind of schematic,
um, uh, summary. But
this is what we have, um,
that it starts off the Berlin genealogies
does have for someone called the
[inaudible] Burlington.
It's changed to burden, uh,
by Calvin burden,
who has a Huguenot quit
Protestant white from friends.
Um, and then, um,
Nathaniel burden to and his
father with two ways, uh,
the Mexican wife,
um,
or Joanna and why from New Hampshire
who is joining this actual mother.
And then in Kelvin burden, his son, um,
first son kill, buys a Torres around
the grandfather and then a book.
And so this is their,
um,
put in genealogy and we'll see that,
two names are being repeated
twice, right? So the name,
the Fangio appears twice and they,
Calvin appears twice.
Definitely foreign of
loves to play with names.
So this is another instance of the non
trivial play with names because we all
know who Calvin is and he is everything
to say about originally was thin and
predestination. Um, John Calvin wreck,
they're looking like someone who would
make that kind of felt stigma about
originals. Then, um, and
this is his treaters, um,
hell than institutes of
the Christian division. Um,
and this is what he
says about original sin.
Original sin therefore seems to be a
hereditary depravity and corruption of our
nature diffused into all the possible.
There's so push first
makes us liable to cause.
So it doesn't really actually take the
reprehensible action of anyone for us to
be liable to cause rough, um, that Ashley,
we inherit them then pull.
The thing is that it is hereditary.
It is passed on from one generation to
another without the full vision of a
person upon which is visited and,
uh,
without even necessarily
and the reprehensible action
on the poet on whom a dad
original sin it's visited.
It simply,
it's something that is
passed on automatically from
one generation to another.
So this,
um,
this long standing tradition of thinking
about an evil that we can escape,
um, that we're just in, in
voluntarily signed up, you know,
onto the school legacy of evil
and punishment of course. Um,
and so this was one I would say,
you know,
this is Joanna's genealogy and this
was also partly Faulkner's genealogy as
well. He's, when the sailing
is a calendars based on
very, very interesting, um,
in this kind of thinking,
of course that is transmitted across time,
across generations.
Um,
but there's another
party to this genealogy,
um,
that Daniel Hawthorne,
we're rarely have seen how
important Hawthorne is.
And it turns out it really is the figure
and was of longstanding relevance to
fatten her up. So the hearth
on Faulkner connection. Uh,
we know that in the scholar leather,
there's the revenant dems there of who
convinced the devil tree with Hesta print.
Um,
and as a laid iron,
just a reverence Whitfield who commits
adultery with adding so that with feel,
oh, and with your Ashlyn making a speech
that sounds almost like themselves,
a speech at the end of
the sky, never. And, um,
then we in light and artist named
Nathaniel this resurrected one more time,
it's almost as if fabulous
just paying this kind of the,
this lovely tribute to an author who's
been very, very important to him.
Um, and so, um,
given the fact that, um, that, that,
that, that the whole, that
connection is actually a connection,
um, by way of the skull. The other, um,
which is in some sense a novel,
not just about sin,
some kind of sin in passing,
um, that nobody that, you know,
demonstrate was only can shake off and
maybe has drew can shake off either the
sin that will stick to you and
follow you wherever you go. Um,
is not really just about that,
but there's also about sexual depravity
or sexual license to some extent,
even though that is not
representative at all, um,
in the scout weather and not really
represented in any ddos in both those
novels, in both the scarlet
letter and as I lay dying, um,
the sexual licenses on the gesture
that we know, the outcome of that,
uh,
of that elicit sexuality in the sense
that we see has to a village of a dog pull
in the sky letter and we see
addys it legitimate son Joel,
uh, in this also connection between
Pearl and jewel as well. Um,
we see has to,
as we see at is a legitimate son,
Jude in SLA done. But in
both those novels, um,
the social license is not
really represented, is not
part of the novel in um,
the light in August after we,
um,
we do see that sexual
license front and center. Um,
and what makes this even more complicated
is that is mapped onto the platform of
ways.
So it is weird combination of uh,
uh,
believe in Calvin is original sin,
comfortable with sexual wireless
on their part of Joanne,
that burden.
Um,
and that is when the
word new row comes out.
This is yet another device,
sashes context for the
use of the word Negro now.
And then she put the Tris beneath so much
rumps our grounds where he would find
her a negative or with her clothing,
have time to ribbons upon
her in the whilst froze with
an inflammation mania and
Barney gleaming in the slow shifting
from one to another of such informally
you're writing attitudes and gestures
as a Beardsley of the time of petroleum.
My hair dryer,
she would be wild in the close feeling
half dark without was with her wild here.
And each strand of which we seem to
come alive. Like October's tentacles,
wow. Pant who really Negro, the Negro.
So it might seem in comprehensible than
someone like John and let her spends all
the time trying to help blacks in the
south who would is on a board of a dozen,
uh,
charities and schools.
Black schools are basically if dedicated
and her entire life to racial uplift
should be doing this. Um, but
I think that it actually is,
I think as far as far as concern,
this incredible sexual license actually
goes hand in hand with a belief in
Calvinist predestination,
right?
If you really believe that you are
going to be stuck with the originals,
then that that is going to be upon you,
that black shadow is going to be
upon you no matter what you do,
then it really doesn't matter what
you do is aware kind of of, of,
of granting of lies. And is
that, you know, if all this,
if you're going to be evil anyway,
no matter what you do,
that you might as well actually be
evil and your conduct as well. Uh,
it's something of that logic.
Uh,
but I don't even think that this
is as large and complex that they,
there's just for, is
just the two sides, um,
of Joanna.
Um,
and maybe that just as
high tower has two phases.
Joanna clearly has two phases
and the whole tradition,
the Calvinist tradition also
has two phases. Um, and,
and that is really foreclose
a contribution to thinking
about this particular
card, uh, theology. Um,
but what we also know that this is,
that thought my tenants to stick in all
kinds of weird details, um, into this.
Otherwise, you know, kind of,
um, just kind of food rest, um,
description of centralizing some,
the hydro, he also has kind of,
we're kind of references
to two other traditions.
One is, um, be late and the other
is patrolling areas. So, um,
this is be as laid,
the famous illustrator [inaudible].
Um, there's a Salamay, um,
showing human beings in this kind
of very erotic and wow gestures.
Um, there's, uh, another
illustration for Oscar was, so,
I mean, and, um, a full
portfolios. Um, it,
um, this is, uh, actually,
uh, not quite a novel,
sort of a beginning of a novel.
Um,
is about to,
um,
Petrolia is the writer
as Taryn can. Um, it,
the reason that is related to, um,
to the Falkland novels of them,
um, is that, especially
in light in August,
is that this novel early novel is about
to foreigners with Greek sounding names
and Coby is and gets in,
in southern Italy, right?
So this is the first instance
of northerners going south
and quite Yankees going
themselves. And as I said, a
bit but similar dynamics. Um,
and Joanna knows that and her father
and the whole family knows that they're
headed as Yankees and Cabo back
business we've seen last time.
So the whole dynamics of people from one
region going south and being hated by
the logos. Um, but in this case,
there's this additional complication
that this is a very coal,
no going to the heart itself.
And in some instances
being heated up by that,
uh, tropical environment, uh,
but basically staying cold
at heart. So this is, uh,
the pendulum swing of Joanna from that
incredible sexualizes to the other side.
And she also,
interestingly enough,
she also uses the word Negro
in that context. When she
swings to the other side,
she was sitting place still on the bed.
Her hands on her land is
still New England phase.
It was still the face of a
spinster prominently bond long,
a little thin,
almost men like in contrast to it who
Lombardi was more originally in softly and
more than ever though she
said at home using detach,
impose a full measure
even to a bastard child.
I would like to see fathers in faces.
Um,
the sentence I think is really interesting
that what is in the parenthesis,
the still face, it has been in
store and then the animal body. Um,
and kind of perfect summary
of the two size of Joanna.
Um,
and there's even for five new very
ungainly syntax of deliberate syntax.
Um, and then the last part of that, um,
the Bastard Negro child and it
is not accidental that there's,
is the moment the Salish
is invoking Calvin,
I would like to see
farther than it was fairs.
And Calvin's Faitas is almost as if
this is the Neil, the 20th century,
in addition to the scar,
that level in a new 20th century addition
to long standing theology of cal.
And the, this is what
happened when you, when you,
when you inherit from
those two traditions, um,
is that you both do good by, um, you know,
by supposedly helping, uh,
blogs. But then you also, um,
engage in this,
uh,
uncontrollable sexual orgy with that.
Um,
and the, the, the, the, um,
the best and Negro child is,
is,
is this kind of also involuntary
outcome of the Union of those two sides.
Um, so, you know, as sort
of easy to, it's the wild.
Joanna is not going to be an easy
person for German prisoners to deal with
regularly. I, anyone, uh,
with have hard time trying to negotiate,
trying to deal with someone like that.
Um,
and Joe Christmases responds is lack this.
at this point in either wanted to go to
school once in to study law with a black
lawyer and wants to turn over all the
lens of all the money that she has in.
It's quite, it's not insignificant. Um,
[inaudible] that all the money to him,
and this is his response to school.
His mouth said a negative school.
Me, yes, that you can go to
Memphis, you can read them,
bought in people's office.
He would teach you long and about a
lot in the office with a neighbor,
lawyer. His mouth said yes. Then I
would turn over all the business to you,
all the money of it so that when you
need money for yourself, you could,
you will know how lawyers
know how to do it.
So he would be helping them out of
darkness and number accused of loving you
even if they found out. But a nigger
in college and niggers lawyer,
his voice had quiet,
not even argumentative,
just prompted there.
We're not looking at one another and
she had not looked up since he entered.
Tell them, tell them niggers
to them and they go it to, um,
incident. Essentially, this is
a moment when Joanna is boat,
completely tone deaf. Um, but also, uh,
just really sad,
you know,
just incredibly sad person that,
um,
this is the best that she can do for him
to choose to, a little embarrassed to.
She's offered a bribe him as well,
just trying to say, you know,
I'm going to turn over
all the money to you. Um,
and it really doesn't matter
if you study along, you know,
the way how to use the money for, you
know, for your own pleasure really.
She's can really spread,
goes up to say that word,
but that's about as she
wants to do the most for him.
And she would not admit to it,
she would not name what
she's turning over to them.
So all that your lips or the
of those unfinished sentences,
she was both tone deaf and bill also
actually at the maximum point of,
of goodwill and love,
maybe even towards him wanting to do the
most fan and his way of responding is,
but being too holy.
Ironic about the work in there.
So I think that the least and
have the, about her as well. Um,
so I think that we can say
that when the word Nigger, um,
is used in that context,
it's also a moment of psychological,
the rest.
And maybe he just even can
bear to knowledge the fact
that she actually wants to
do so much for him.
You know,
I think that that would be one way to
read that that is actually not, um,
a moment when there's no love fellow
that, you know, that, that, that,
that is, that romance
is over, is not that,
but then maybe it's too much.
And that the way the key is responding
to that is by being told is cynical,
is a terrible in their
eye about the whole thing.
So the state is really open
to any number of readings. Um,
all we know that it is definitely not an
innocent word when it's used by oneself
that is asked which hodge,
um,
and is painful to use as when
there's a tribute to oneself.